this is Andrew asked him for some
relationship advice Gang Gang is that
Andrew from bleach media I don't know
what that is
what's up Theo and Brandon I've got a
crazy relationship advice question so I
recently broke up with my girl we've
been we were dating for a year and a
half and it got to the point where she
was just bringing me down all the time
telling me that I need to see a
therapist hmm
telling me that I need to read books I
don't read books so I broke up with her
but the thing is so we just try to help
they'll live together for the next
couple weeks she's gonna move out in
about two weeks but my question is I
want to know for the next two weeks is
it acceptable to have a little slam
peace over I live in the basement my ex
girl lives upstairs she might not even
know if I had some little Sloot over oh
my that'd be okay would that just kind
of be pushing the boundaries at all
jhemini I fully support him I'm the
roommate and best friend
I got looks like Hilary Swank bro Buzzz
Buzzz slam slam peaches are mine yeah I
mean it's not like you're stalking women
on fine that was not a dig at your buddy
I think Hilary Swank is one of the
finest young men that's ever well she
did work and Million Dollar Baby oh dude
definitely she's definitely better than
some of these oh definitely some of the
bantamweight fighters I've seen Reese
I'll take her over Vin Diesel ye what
I'm saying is first of all are you sure
you don't live with your mom your mom
might have to be having an erroneous
converse say a relationship daddy
also could you let's say you do have a
bunch of slam pieces by
to get into that basement with your best
friend can you wait two weeks could you
hold out two weeks so the girlfriend
doesn't have to see it is the other
thing I don't know if I believe you have
a girlfriend so that out the elephant in
the room it sounds like you and your
brother won't move out it sounds like
you won't move out guys it's like a real
problem yeah and first of all yeah [ __ ]
while you're indoors cuz in two weeks
you're outdoors dude alright it doesn't
sound like you guys have a huge problem
a huge plan
I didn't hear like a printing press
going on down there I didn't see anybody
I didn't see any like crafts or
mercantile Lurie in the background no
textiles do you guys have two weeks to
get your [ __ ] together and you're
stalking people on the gram bro some
people on the ground also called women
slam pieces I would fix that in this
culture of my man good luck brother but
yeah I think I don't know what do you
think cat your woman I really don't
believe any of us Wow because you're
telling me the girlfriend lives upstairs
he lives in the basement with his best
friend yeah it's and you're trying to
bring a girl to the basement to [ __ ]
yeah I'm almost positive it's his mom
she wanted to read books and go to
therapy
yeah dude case salty it's your mom ton
make you a better person bro yeah he's
young too man oh this kids probably 13
or 14 have you ever heard the term slam
peace I have only from people who don't
get laid yes correct
yeah and I God I was in New Jersey
Liddell fiha one time in the middle of
the night and uh I was at a bars in a
house there was a club a nightclub
somebody had some zoning loophole it was
a house bar club it was a house bar club
it was a house my didn't walk into
somebody's house into a nightclub like
in a neighborhood dude really really
bizarre call the house four people were
dancing bro they had a DJ every between
every song they would stop into the
Eagles fight song oh well and then at
one point the DJ came on her is like who
wants to [ __ ] one of these slam pigs
tonight like so slam pigs I left and
what girls like yeah I'm a slam Pig yeah
so I'm gonna shoved out the window for
no reason yeah
was bad places just this was out
Manayunk before they before it got
gentrified it was a real [ __ ]
d have you heard the term slam peace
slam peace my [ __ ] Hulk Hogan was
crazy
the chick was wearing a she was wearing
a bob Brutus the barber beefcake t-shirt
as well one of the women a slam Pig yeah
a slam pig so we're gonna be heavier
woman and they love to rest on their
area anyway you get a new jersey and PA
man people love wrestling
Springsteen all that oh good luck dude
we solve this case
[Music]